elle va faire quelque chose manille
terre amie à quelque chose je vois
partir du district
ouais ya un déplacement vous partez à
plusieurs et vous ferai quelque chose
avec des audiences en afrique mais c'est
écrit sur ses écrits sur cette finale
avait causé des dégâts mais est-ce que
tu as une question à lui poser peut-être
sentimentale ou non pour moi plus
important c'est la santé voilà je vous
demandais ce que je vais avoir la santé
et ma famille et aucun souci après comme
je l ai voyons voilà voilà des petits
voyous qui voit des mauvaises chaussures
qui dit rien on regarde pour mathieu
tout elle a conduit cinéma cinémas à
signer tu as eu des propositions qu'il
aimerait répéter débuté à tu vois alors
malade a annoncé mais c'est vrai que
j'ai toujours aimé enfin j'ai fait du
têt plus jeunes ça fait partie aussi
d'avoir une proposition au cinéma